hi this is Mark and I'm the CEO and
founder of
tungo if you haven't heard of tungle
before we are a service for busy
professionals to help you find a time to
meet with colleagues with clients no
matter which company they work for or
which calendar application they're
using we've launched in May of 2009 and
since then we haven't had a month where
we didn't see a 30% month-to-month
growth rate and we're using 30 of the
Fortune 100 and there's 7 00
universities all around the world using
tungle including Harvard MIT and sead
and so on we've made a lot of updates
based on user feedback and there's one
of them that I wanted to talk to you a
bit about today have you ever been
invited to a meeting and you're
wondering to yourself who's this person
inviting me to this meeting or better
yet who are these other people that have
been invited to this meeting and what is
their background and what do they do
well today we bring the power of tongle
for easy scheduling with that of
LinkedIn so you can find out the
background of the the people that you're
going to be meeting we've been working
with the LinkedIn team and apis for this
easy integration uh but it shows you
that when you bring together the power
of two services for business
professional how it can make your life
easier for you our users so let me show
you how that
works so Richard here has sent me a
tungle invitation and he's trying to
schedule a meeting with me in multiple
people so when I click on the link
provided in the email I'll get to see
the times that he's proposing for the
meeting now you'll notice that my
calendar is also shown in this because I
happen to be a tongle user so I can make
an informed decision but if I wasn't a
tungle user I Richard could still use
tongle to schedule a meeting with me now
I can see that other people have also
been invited to this meeting now I may
not know who jaku is but because of this
integration that we did with LinkedIn if
he happens to be a LinkedIn user I see a
little I in that appears next to their
name so so when I click on it I get to
see who they are what they do where they
come from so I can better prepared for
this meeting pretty cool
stuff now I can simply highlight the
times that I'm ready for this meeting
and submit my
availability so let us know what you
think about this integration we're
really excited about it um and if you
don't have already your account on tungo
go to the bottom of this post there's a
link there uh where you can sign up for
your free account
and in the meantime just enjoy tongling
thank you